foreign
years of my life
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca
Rocky
my dad
this is built on their shoulders
[Music]
let me get all the grab no I signed an
autograph but you get off my car you
don't remember me huh
[Music]
how long were you locked up 18 Years bro
just got out last week
I know I've been away a long time but I
kept myself in shape I still got gas in
the tank come by the gym
thank you
[Music]
carers what happened with you too oh you
can tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though man I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute
I know what you doing Donnie you don't
owe this dude nothing
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I vouch for you you think
you mad trying to spending half your
life in the cell
why did somebody else live your life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something is going on with you Batman
was like family
[Music]
are we past talking then maybe you just
have to find out
I recognize mine I know that they needed
me somatic stress watching manifest got
my only fair I ain't scared of death did
you hear me
did you hear me yet
I need you to make all your fear
they're called a guilt
let go of whatever was and walk into
what is I feel those chains are breaking
yeah
[Music]